[Applause]
[Music]
it's undeniable that the rise of the ufc
has been historic
in 20 years the company has taken a
sport which was illegal in many states
and turned it into an anchor product for
the biggest sports network in the world
i don't care what color you are what
country you come from or what language
you speak we're all human beings and for
some reason fighting is in our dna man
at the center of it all is dana white
and he's as big of a character as you
can find shut the [ __ ] up you
scumbag
dana white is the id of the ufc in many
ways
but behind the bluster and hyperbole
there's a monumental business story
happening because the ufc doesn't just
want to be mainstream it wants to be the
most popular sport in the world
and even that ambition may be too
limited
the crown jewel of super agent arya
emmanuel's endeavor empire the ufc is
influencing not just sports but culture
media and entertainment and for them
nothing not a pandemic or bruising legal
fight will stand in their way it's hard
for people to really wrap the brains
around how big this business can really
be but i get it i know what this thing
is capable of and i always have
[Music]
to understand one of the most
interesting stories in the world of
sports and business you have to come
here to las vegas
it's not about betting it's not about
the new football team or even the hockey
team that everyone's so excited about
it's about one sport the ufc and it's
about one guy dana white
more than 20 years ago white convinced
his high school friends frank and
lorenzo fertitta to go in with him on
buying the ufc
for two million dollars
[Music]
today estimates value the ufc at closer
to nine or ten billion dollars
it's the centerpiece of one of the
largest talent and entertainment
companies in the world
and three years into a contract with
espn the ufc is growing faster than ever
but to understand how we got to this
moment in 2021
you have to understand the last two
decades
and the best person to ask about that is
dana himself in his natural habitat hey
dana crazy awesome
this is just an incredible office
come over here
this is my bar oh my gosh
and this is my gym
i'll come in here in the morning i work
out shower and then start my day right
[Music]
as i've dug into this business
i mean it's mind-blowing i think for
anyone who's looking at it and say it's
two million bucks like i mean
and look what it's become the landscape
in the backyard is worth two million
dollars you know what i mean it's true
right oh it's crazy
we bought the company
and
this wasn't allowed on pay-per-view
porn
was on pay-per-view and you could pay
for it but you could not pay for the ufc
we bought the company and our goal was
to get it onto free tv
which everybody thought was impossible
at the time
because it was illegal
yeah in some states in some states yeah
it was illegal in some states
in fact as of 2001 only two states
sanctioned ufc fights but after a lot of
investment and a lot of visits to state
capitals not only does all of north
america sanction fights but the ufc
broadcast to more than 900 million
households all around the world
the growth of the company in the sport
is in large part because of dana but
also that the ufc is set up much
differently than other pro sports like
the nfl or the nba so what makes you
different from
adam silver or roger goodell i think the
big difference in what makes us
i wouldn't say better
but easier to manage than those things
there's one guy that makes all the
decisions
and that's me yeah
i make all the decisions you know
when i want to do something
we're doing it
[Music]
unlike many other sports leagues that
have team owners players unions or
governing bodies who weigh in on
decisions the ufc well it has dana
that's allowed him to be aggressive over
the last 20 years of business and
especially through the pandemic
in the united states the ufc was the
first major sporting event to resume
operations when it hosted ufc 249 in may
of 2020. tonight the first major u.s
sporting event since the copen 19
shutdowns will take place right here in
jacksonville
getting international fighters into the
octagon proved to be more challenging
but dana had an idea for that as well
the ufc is apparently building a
facility on a private island that
they're calling fight island now is that
a clever name no is it the perfect name
yes
that started with dana saying i've got
an idea i want to buy my own private
island i want to own it myself i want to
set all the rules i can do anything i
want to do on my island and we're going
to put fights on in that island we're
not going to have to listen to anybody
because it's going to be my island
this is lawrence epstein ufc coo and
often when dana has an idea he's one of
the people tasked to turn it into a
reality and sort of my response was okay
dude i'm not sure that's going to work
yeah but you know there's got to be an
opportunity for us out there and
ultimately we put on these series of
events in yoss island and so it all
started with a crazy idea of dana like
i'm literally going to buy an island i'm
gonna own it and i'm gonna be the king
of that island and i'm gonna do whatever
i want
keeping fights going during the pandemic
was important to dana white
critics and health officials warned
against matches at one point even espn's
parent company disney had to step in
when the ufc sought to avoid california
state guidelines by holding the event on
tribal lands but at a time when most
other sports had been almost entirely
shut down the ufc was able to produce
matches for their fighters and deliver
on their contract with espn it's one of
the things i'm the most proud of out of
my whole 20-year career with the ufc is
that we didn't lay off any of our
employees and we honored all our fighter
contracts and you know everybody made a
living and got paid through covet
since the ufc resumed live events in may
of 2020 they've conducted about 55 000
tests of athletes and staff with a
positivity rate of about one percent
but as vaccines rolled out through the
country and restrictions began to ease
the ufc was ready to bring fans back and
in sin city they wanted it back in a big
way ufc president dana white said that
conor mcgregor versus dustin poiret is
happening july 10th at the t-mobile
arena at full capacity
we're here for ufc 264 and for the first
time since the start of the pandemic las
vegas has sold out venues up and down
the strip
[Music]
vegas was alive again with activity
thanks in large part to the main event
match between conor mcgregor and dustin
poirier and despite rising cases in
nevada and the rise of the delta variant
around the country fans couldn't wait to
be back in fact t-mobile arena sold out
its more than 20 000 seats in just
seconds what's up everybody how are you
this was of course back in july and you
may remember the actual match ended up
not going past the first round after
conor mcgregor suffered a gruesome leg
injury but for the sport of combat
fighting it's never been more successful
i mean this isn't even the event it's a
press conference do you respect dustin
poirier no matter what happens on
saturday night i don't give a [ __ ] about
them to be honest i don't give a rat's
ass about them
you've got your die hard fans a lot of
them were sitting out there
today how do you get to
the the more casual
sports fan you know i consider myself a
you know pretty big sports fan but
candidly i've never been a huge ufc fan
how do you get to me yeah so what
happens is
through the pandemic obviously we gained
a lot of fans because we were the only
thing on tv people tuned in people
watched we gained a lot of fans because
there was nothing to gamble on so sports
bettors started betting on ufc and if
you're going to watch ufc you're going
to end up loving it there's there's no
way that it isn't exciting to you and
and not fun to watch
and now in year three of their seven
year deal with espn more and more people
than ever are being exposed to ufc and
mma fighting the ufc on espn
[Applause]
you think you want to be on espn you
think that's where you need to be you're
a sport you don't really realize the
impact until you get on espn yeah the
impact has been massive tell me about
that like in what way turn your tv on at
three o'clock in the afternoon three
o'clock in the morning six am that bug
is up there that says conor mcgregor
versus poirier
every single week that's up there
and these fighters names start to drill
into people's heads you do that over a
seven year period
it's massive yeah not just for the brand
but for the individual fighters too
the ufc is also important to espn in an
age of cord cutting espn is looking to
grow their espn plus streaming audience
it's a different day and time with this
younger generation they're all cord
cutters and we have not only do we have
great content and a massive fan base now
that we've built over the last 20 years
to finally get to espn where we can
actually
add value to them
and
our demographic are the cord cutters
right the ufc
lightweight
championship of the world
but the road to espn 20 years ago for
the ufc sounded laughable dana
congratulations on your first show
that's got to feel good thank you very
much james i appreciate it we're very
excited
after years of investment in just making
the sport legal they still needed a way
to grow their audience
so they did what anyone in the early
2000s would do they started a reality
show we picked who we believe are the
best guys in this country right now do
you want to be a fighter that's the
question
when you look at every metric every
single metric relating to the ufc
whether it's number of fans
profitability ratings pay-per-view buys
there's this inflection point and that
inflection point is the ultimate fighter
reality show it was ruled a unanimous
decision
spike tv starts television network for
men we pitch the ultimate fighter to
them and they want nothing to do with it
so
we say to them what if we pay for it
they like that idea a lot yeah
the last [ __ ] thing you want to do is
get kicked off this show the ufc would
put 10 million dollars into creating the
first season of the show we all have to
drink equally
dana oversaw the production himself and
starred in the show i don't want you
here and i'll throw you out of this gym
so fast your head will spin
that paid off and the ultimate fighter
would go on to be one of the biggest
draws for the network and run for 14
seasons and from the popularity of the
show the ufc would only grow
they then moved to fox sports and helped
launch their fs1 channel but it also
helped connect dana with one of the
world's best known agents ari emanuel
get james cameron on the phone get dana
gordon on the phone
if you're not familiar with our emanuel
you might know the entourage character
of ari gold that was based off of him
this is now the biggest agency in the
world
and i'm the head of it
he now runs endeavor a newly public
entertainment juggernaut we had come up
with a research department to look at
ratings and helps us sign people helps
us keep shows on the air
different from any other agency at the
time
and the guy comes in to me and he says
well here's the number on spike i go
holy cow that's incredible i'm doing the
agent signing thing i'm calling him
every day it's a long game a year later
dana calls me and says if you can get me
a meeting with hbo boxing i'll sign with
you now i'm a character on a show
right
honey you know i've done most of the
programming i was like this is like
like simple you're like this is the
thing this is my face
i should have just gone through that
right
[Music]
as arya explains that meeting didn't go
well but white did end up signing with
ahri as a client
and then in 2016 when the fertitta
brothers decided to sell the ufc it
would be ari and endeavor who would
ultimately buy a controlling stake in
the ufc valuing the company at about 4
billion
remember the ufc was bought by the
fertittas and dana for about 2 million
roughly 15 years earlier when you jump
out of bed you better be ready to fight
you better be ready to kick ass and win
and since the sale ari and endeavour
have used the whole of the company's
portfolio to help grow the ufc even more
when you think about
and
we can do this on many things
we call it inside the company
architecture how we take elements of the
portfolio and use other elements to
build value across the platform
and if you think about where we started
at the ufc when we got it to where it is
now that's only because of the
architectural platform of the company
international sales gambling
licensing video games
today we are going to do the
cheeseburger crunchwrap the non-scripted
group in wme
just sold the show to food network
four episodes with dana this is so good
and that's gonna expand our audience so
that's the architecture of the business
constantly adding value adding audience
growing market share growing awareness
[Music]
and while many aspects of endeavor
suffered from the pandemic hollywood was
essentially closed for business the ufc
thrived
so much so that in april of 2021 they
would buy out the remainder of the ufc
from investment firms kkr and silver
lake as part of a plan to take endeavour
public
in fact according to ahri owning all of
the ufc was critical to convincing wall
street that his ambitions were sound
the next phase continuing to take the
ufc business global
10 percent of the ufc audience is in the
united states
90 is international
the economics are switched 90 of the
economics is domestic 10 is interesting
i think there's a couple sports that are
global
soccer's global
basketball is of some extent
but this is for sure global
[Music]
[Applause]
so
this is where i spend a majority of my
day
basically
me
one of my lawyers
and two of our matchmakers we sit in
this room
most of the day every day
these are the fights that we're building
this is all the parts of the world that
the fighters are coming from and where
we want to go and what we want to do
and finding rising talent from around
the world makes a big difference to the
ufc business when we go into these new
markets for instance when conor mcgregor
became a star he ignited europe whaley
zhang our chinese world champion when
she became a champion she ignited china
when you have somebody who looks like
you talks like you and comes from where
you come from and they're looked at as
the baddest human being on planet earth
you rally behind these people and and
it becomes big and then eventually once
you do this you know in different parts
of the world
you've got a real global sport
fighters have and will always be the
engine of the ufc
but if there is one speed bump in the
road to ufc global domination it may be
the multi-billion dollar anti-trust
lawsuit it's currently facing from
former ufc fighters we filed this case
in december of 2014 on behalf of
a group of mixed martial arts fighters
who fought for the ufc on our way over
to uh
the courthouse now in broad terms the
case is an antitrust case where we're
claiming that the ufc is both a monopoly
and a monopsony meaning it is a dominant
seller of mixed martial arts services
and a dominant buyer of mixed martial
arts services
the lawsuit claims the ufc quote engaged
in an illegal scheme to eliminate
competition and that allows it to pay
fighters quote a fraction of what they
would earn in a competitive marketplace
and then it has used those tactics to
bad ends
including suppressing the compensation
of the ufc fighters and making it
difficult for fighters to get free
agency and have mobility and control
their own careers
maybe unsurprisingly dana white doesn't
see it like that we bought the company
in 2001. we didn't start making money
till like six or seven right ever since
the day we bought the company
fighter pay has gone like this and it's
gone up even more in the last five years
and it's going to go up even more in the
next five years
william isakson a lawyer for the ufc
said in a statement to bloomberg that
average fighter compensation has risen
by over 600 percent since 2005.
but according to the plaintiffs in the
case while ufc fighter pay has increased
the percentage of revenue fighters
received has remained fairly stable at
around 20 percent and what this analysis
shows is that if the ufc
was competitive and did not allegedly
violate the antitrust laws it would pay
its fighters 50 or more of the revenues
it's generated just like baseball
just like hockey just like basketball
and if that were to happen if if instead
of paying 20 percent of the revenues
generated it paid 50 or more of the
revenues generated the fighters would
have made 1.6 billion dollars more
during the period 2010 to 2017.
usually when you're facing this kind of
legal battle you tend to stay quiet but
for dana he's not afraid of letting you
know just how he feels we built an
industry from nothing where if you
followed the lines
of how many people have benefited and
made money from this company and we
changed the pay structure so that
everybody makes money not just the top
guys
in boxing the top guys make millions and
everybody else starves
everybody makes money here everybody
makes a good living and
there's enough money to reinvest back
into the sport yeah grow the sport and
grow the brand we're growing a real
business we're heading into this
this this country where everybody gets a
trophy and everybody should get this and
everybody should get that
when i leave
when i leave maybe it'll turn uh this
place will be left to the hyenas and
then come in and rip this thing apart
but as long as i'm here
yeah it ain't gonna happen
[Music]
i have a lawyer that who does a lot of
them the lawsuit is likely to take years
to resolve and for dana the best way to
grow fighter pay is to continue the
mission of growing the business
and making more money for everyone
[Music]
it's a huge weekend for entertainment in
las vegas
a highly anticipated ufc fight filling
in the t-mobile arena tonight
it's fight night in vegas
as fans and celebrities stream in to see
the fight dana is behind the scenes
making sure everything around the entire
production is happening up to his
standards you are there like literally
like right there against the octagon 100
there's a telephone there
that's connected to the truck so things
that i don't like that are going on i
pick up the phone and i call the truck
whether it's an in-house production
issue or an on tv production issue
you're producing the show in real time
yeah my guys are so good that this thing
is dialed in and they know exactly what
i want
we're one of the few major sports
organizations that produce all of our
own content so everything that you see
whether it's on espn whether it's on
global in brazil whether it's on bt in
the uk and list goes on that stuff is
all produced by us and it's produced in
a way that has a global mindset so when
you're in china and you're watching ufc
that market is specific to the way the
content is created
when people ask me about the upside for
this thing i'm always like how many
people are there on earth 7 billion so
my long-term goal is to put on fights
that are doing 5 million 10 million 15
million pay-per-view buys and this thing
is truly the first real big global sport
and we have no seasons
we go 365.
52 weeks a year we're going we got
through this covet thing this company
from all of my employees my executive
team and to the core unit over an
endeavor
we're like this right now
we're as tight as tight can be we're all
in the same mission we're all on the
same page and uh we're very scary group
of people right now we're good we're
we're going to crush this thing shy of a
meteor hitting the earth i think we can
get through anything
you